en avril 2010 est le parlement hongrois
va t'en procédure accélérée une loi qui
réglemente sévèrement l'installation des
universités étrangères
un texte qui selon ses détracteurs
visent particulièrement l'université
d'europe centrale financée par le
milliardaire américain d'origine
hongroise george soros en novembre 2019
l'université d'europe centrale est
contrainte de déménager l'essentiel de
ses activités à vienne car son
implantation à budapest et non conformes
à la loi sur les universités étrangères
en vertu de cette loi les établissements
étrangers implantés en hongrie doivent
disposer d'un cursus et d'un campus dans
leur pays d'origine
la loi exige également la conclusion
d'une convention internationale avec
l'état d'origine de l'établissement ce
qui n'est pas le cas de l'université
d'europe centrale fondé conformément au
droit new yorkais la justice européenne
qui vient de condamner budapest estime
que la législation hongroise se heurte
aux dispositions de la charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne
celle qui est relative à la liberté
académique notamment et à la liberté
d'entreprise à l'annoncé du jugement la
ministre de la justice hongroise a
estimé que budapest était victime d'un
deux poids deux mesures sont davantage
d'explications elle a précisé sur sa
page facebook que la hongrie allait je
cite appliquer le jugement de la cour
européenne dans l'intérêt du peuple
hongrois